so everyone thanks for coming this is
amazing so I thought I'd try something a
little bit different today I I've given
a few workshops on numpy pandas before
that kind of thing but usually I have a
block of six hours and here we're we're
limited to two hours so what I'm going
to do is maybe something a little bit
dangerous who's heard of pair
programming
alright heard of mob programming
alright mob programming you take the
pair and the other person is everyone
else I'm going to pair program this with
all of you in the room as I live as we
go I saw a couple of gasps over there oh
this is we'll see how that goes all
righty so first of all a quick systems
check does everyone have them working
pandas install anyone who does not have
the ability to run that line all right
if you don't I recommend using condor
anaconda so if you go to continuum that
IO you can download it there it's
wonderful it's fast it's free it's not
pip install pandas assuming you have
Python working and just four people yes
I prefer three these slides should work
on both but if you have the choice go
300 me interrupt a minute so if there's
questions I've got the microphone here
so people can hear we're also live
streaming so if you speak to the mic
then people listening to the live stream
can can hear what you're asking and oh
and if you're on the live stream I'm
going to be monitoring the Twitter which
is the at PI data Seattle 2017 so ask
your questions there sorry to interrupt
thank you alrighty so just well the last
few people get pandas installed I love
to do a quick show of hands how many
people are consider themselves
academics how many people are software
developers all right how many of you
have used pandas before okay this is
what I say I will not get offended if
you'd like to leave the room to go to a
more interesting workshop I'm going to
take you from the ground up here okay
no worries about that okay and this is
how we're going to do it I'm going to
have cells like this and I can type in
them and I'm just going to be able to
run them in real time
cool all right I'm assuming everyone's
done that line now so a little bit about
me well the last few people install as
we said in the introduction I consider
myself a lapsed computational physicist
I have a PhD in functional neuroscience
and then I worked on some statistical
problems in disease transmission at
Princeton and now for just over a year
I've been a data scientist with CBRE
I also run the advanced topics on
machine learning interest group in
Seattle if anyone's based in the Seattle
area come join us
all right a little bit about the hero of
the story I love coffee I am completely
addicted to caffeine and during my PhD
this was my best friend
now I worked in a small department at
the University of Warwick and we had
this wonderful espresso machine it was
wonderful for two reasons and one was
that it gave us wonderful coffee on
demand and two was that it had this
little display and then you could hit a
few buttons and it would tell you
exactly how many espressos it had brewed
to date so we wrote an Android app we
sent around people in the department and
we said when you go get a coffee
just interrogate the Machine and tell us
and put into the Android app how many
coffees it's on right now and they
started at about Coffee 400 and it ended
at about maybe 27,000 it's about
standard for a math department so what
we're going to do today is we're going
to work through an exploratory analysis
just a basic analysis of the time series
that came out of this trophy dataset
just to tell you a bit more about that
so we're going to be doing this as a way
to expose you to the pandas API pandas
is a huge package very powerful and it
can do a lot of things we're going to
try to use it in a natural way such that
by the end if you've never seen panels
you have a good idea for how to
work with it get a feel for it slides
are available at this github link there
are two notebooks one of them is the one
I'm running through now and one of them
is called solutions and that one
contains what I'm hoping I'm going to
type at the end of this if you want to
follow along please do if you want to
skip ahead that's fine
and the pentose documentation is really
wonderful so don't hesitate to Google
things as you go I'm gonna try to fill
in the blanks about the methods I'm
using as we go and hopefully give you a
little bit about that so this time
series database this time series data
set what does it look like it's
literally got a row for a timestamp 2015
October 3rd 10:00 and 4:00 in the
morning it has a number of coffee's
brewed to date 11200 11 and then it has
a contributor so when you install this
Android I could ask you for your name
the first time and I just let sends an
extra data point saying who entered that
row in the data set and so the questions
we're going to address today who are the
contributors to this data set who is it
that gave those data points what are the
department's weekday coffee habits is it
Monday it's a difficult day and the
after the weekend you come in you have
some coffee is it Friday it's the last
day of the week and then how much coffee
are people drinking in a per capita base
all right so let's begin if you're using
a knife - notebook you want to type this
if you're using spider or a rectal or
anything like that you don't need that
second line what that second line does
is it just tells pandas and matplotlib
under under the hood that if I ask you
for a plots just show me the plot
immediately under the self all right so
let's run them
everyone happy so far any questions all
right so let's import some data this is
what all of our cells where we have to
type things and look like right now so
I'm going to get rid of this how to
import data in pandas that's kind of a
number one question is - is there data
manipulation we need to get it into the
package so the first thing we're going
to do is when the pull from the data
data file called Coffey's dot csv and
the easy way to do that is hey penguins
go read a CSV all right done no errors
that went just great Pandit is able to
import from directly from sequel it's
able to import hdf5 files it's able to
import from Jason and all sorts of other
formats very very flexible what does the
data look like well the easiest way to
check is just say hey - what does the
data look like and it looks like that
now that's a lot of data and I don't
particularly like the format of it so
I'm gonna skip ahead immediately and say
hey beta dot head
show me the first few rows of this data
set all right so what we can observe
immediately is we have an index on the
Left that's just running from 0 1 2 3 4
all the way up to the number of rows we
have and then we have three columns the
first one is the timestamp column and
that contains this kind of information
here coffees and contributor does anyone
notice any problems with this data set
I'm sorry missing data right listen data
comes in the form of these lines that
means not a number probably at the CSV
there was nothing in that field anything
else
okay so everything here is a float where
as we'd expect coffees to be integers
how about this guy turns out when I
wrote this app I didn't do any
validation so you could write whatever
garbage you want so that's not good so
we immediately have a few things we need
to clean and that's what this so an
index in three columns and then you guys
have highlighted already the three
problems should that are immediately
apparent with this data set there are
going to be others because no data is
ever clean all right let's look at that
string in the third row we're going to
use these methods called block or dot I
lock so I'm going to do data log too
because I want the third row all right
in areas the third row has a timestamp a
coffee is in a contributor field does
anyone know the difference between got
lock and dialog
one is strings ones numbers okay so what
Locke does is it a location-based
accessor and it looks for something
that's present in your index now here I
said lock of two and two is in my index
and it's my third row so that's perfect
I lock is an integer lookup and not just
it's like accessing a list in Python or
an umpire array you just pass it the
index of where you want to go down the
data frame so in this case I can do
exactly the same with I'll all can get
the same data back because index two
points to Row two perfect everyone happy
with that so the number of coffees here
is definitely a string something we'll
have to fix welcome back to that let's
take a look at that any end and in fact
why don't we look at that at the first
five values in coffees now coffees is a
column of the data frame so if I say
data coffees what am i accessing in here
I've got a series so this is just the
values in that column and I can access I
can index them using square brackets
like I would a normal list or an array
so if I say hey give me the five first
then we have the five first elements in
that series so the difference between a
series and the data frame is that a data
frame contains multiple columns all of
which can be viewed as series and will
be coming will be juggling the two quite
often
how's my speed is everyone keeping up
okay right
all right how long is the dataset I've
put in a little bit of a cheat here but
I think anyone in in Python wouldn't
know what to use if I wanted the length
of any issue though 671 data points
what else can we find out well we've
used dot head to look at the first few
rows we can use dot describe and this
can return a number of things based on
what's in the data frame but if we do it
just as is what do we get well we get it
looks like another data frame actually
the index is a bunch of strings but this
is a data frame there's a column for
every column that we have timestamp
coffees and contributor and then there
are a few different objects in there so
there's a count how many columns are
there how many objects are in the
timestamp column 671 and that's the
length of our data frames that's great
but in coffees they're only 658
different objects and that's because we
spotted some na and some no values
contributor it doesn't look like it's
missing anything so that's great how
many unique values well we only have
nine different people contributing to
this data set unique timestamps it's
great that they're all unique because in
theory they should all be following each
other and no two people should be using
the app at the same time and then the
top and they're the most frequent this
is just the the first value and the
timestamp and this is their so this is
the most common value in the timestamp
and because they're all unique they're
all as frequency each other so here's
just picked a random one and it said
that the frequency of that is one the
two people apparently entered that there
were seven 5216 coffees because that's a
frequency of two
so we are missing some data and so we're
going to have to fix that we can either
drop those rows because they're not
contributing anything or we can try to
interpolate over the NA ends and we'll
do both today but what so a data frame
contains several columns and each of
those columns can be viewed so columns
go down we pull up all right this is a
data frame you can view the timestamp
column as a series you can view the
coffee's column as a series fact why
don't we do this if I say hey data dot
coffees I'm accessing the coffee's
column and the type of this is a pandas
series object whereas the type of the
data is a data frame object there are
two ways to access a series from data
frame I like the dot notation I find
it's nice and clean but you can also
access it using string
okay
all right by the way shout out as much
as you like I like the back and forth
okay so we spotted that we're missing
values and coffees so we're going to try
to figure out where coffees is known and
see if there are any patterns there so
my hint here is use dot is no method and
then boolean indexing what does this
mean well we have data and we can look
at is know right off the bat all right
can we spot any throughs anywhere is it
true
so this is now asking for if this value
no at any of these points in the data
frame if I want it for the coffees only
what would I have to change
so again thought coffees that is no
awesome alright and that's not return to
series again now the great thing about
this is its return to series with the
same index that we have on our data
frame and it's obviously the same size
as we have to so what I can do is I can
use this as a boolean index and I can
say why don't you return to me the data
where data is coffees is know just by
doing that and so I have pulled out all
of the rows where coffees is Mel right
now it looks like they're spread pretty
mature over time we start in October
2011 and there's still some nulls in
2013
it looks like it's by a mix of
contributors and indeed we can confirm
everything is now in there
so how about that problem with the
strings in the coffee's column well I
can say what's good D type with the data
type of all of the columns in my data
frame and what do we see that they're
all objects the contributor column makes
sense that it's an object because object
is what timeless uses when it means
strings but surely the timestamp column
needs to be a date/time objects and it
would make sense that the coffee's
column at least be some sort of
numerical type right should be probably
an ends it could be a float if we really
wanted so D types so tight is applied to
an object so here if I apply it to data
I get that data is a data frame if I
apply it to data dot d types I should
get that's a series and that's because
if I look at what they did the d-type on
its own gives me back it's a series
where the indices are the names of my
columns and then the values are the type
that that column is so del D types is
looking at the column it's looking at
all of the elements in that column and
it's pulling from that to say these are
objects or these are floating point
numbers d types should work on series
too I think
yep d type always an object d type comes
from numpy if you've ever used that and
numpy arrays can contain floating points
they could be integers they could be all
sorts of different d-types
so here what we're saying is these are
all objects and that doesn't make sense
we want the data to be in the right
format so we can analyze it correctly so
let's inspect within that timestamp
column because those timestamps need to
be daytime objects Python has a great
day time library pandas does a lot of
great stuff on top of that so we want to
use it so print the first element in the
series let's see also the series is
referring to you is the timestamp column
so if I say data dot timestamp that will
print the first element and how about
the type of the first element well I can
print the type of data timestamp and I
want to access the first element here so
the first element looks like this and
it's a string object does anyone know
why it might be a string object instead
of a date/time
I imported it from the CSV if you're not
familiar with the CSV it's like a really
basic text file now Excel can open these
it's called comma separated value and
it's just a list of all of your all of
your data separated by commas and
because it's a plain text thing it's
pretty dumb and we don't know that these
things should be
daytime's so they've been read in
strings I actually consider myself
pretty fortunate that panelist was
intelligent enough to interpret most of
the rest as floats so one more thing we
need to add to our cleaning list is we
own the timestamps to be daytime objects
and not strings all right so this is
everything we found so far that's wrong
the time time column contains strings
that they should be date types the
coffee's column contains both no values
and we saw at least one string so we
need to clean all of that up so that was
our kind of first pass we're going to do
some cleaning and then after that we'll
answer some of those questions all quick
show of hands for how many people are
following along in the notebook how are
you finding it speed is okay yeah all
right don't hesitate to shout out any
questions all right let's clean this up
the coffee's column should contain only
numerical data
pandas ever wonderful provides us with
this method called two numeric so if I
say hey take the coffee's take data
coffees which is a series and set it
equal to the numeric of data coffees is
it that simple is it really going to
work well the answer here is no never
that simple but it's very close if we
look at this error really quickly we see
that it was unable to parse a string
testing that was our string the third or
fourth column right 34th row what it's
not saying is I was able to parse all of
those n/a ends if I'm missing a value
and you tell me to turn something into a
numerical column I'll just ignore those
because those are you know an n/a n is a
valid number surprisingly but what he
couldn't do is parse the string testing
now we're going to use something that's
a keyword argument to two numeric we're
going to say errors coerce and what that
says is anytime you find an error just
dump it and turn it into an N a N and
that's pretty helpful because we only
had one string I can tell you guys I
know the data said you should have
checked but we only had one string and
it's not providing us any information we
don't know how many coffees there was on
that time so if I run this cell now
these are now numerical and I can check
that let me comment this line out and
then I'm going to say theta dot D types
we have now a numerical object the whole
column contains numerical objects we
don't contain strings anymore what we do
have are so many ends and that's finally
we're expecting this
they are popular
so I've taken a copy of the coffee
series I've cast it as a numerical and
I've said anytime you hit something that
you can't cast to a numerical by
yourself just get rid of it and then set
that back into the coffees column in my
data frame and I'm able to do that
because this operation doesn't change
the index right so data about coffees is
a series but it still has an index and
when you try to do equalities and pandas
it compares the indices all right we
solved one of our problems and that was
easier than I thought so moving on it
contains some intends there are several
ways to deal with these as we said one
of them you could just pretend they
don't exist just drop the rows you could
also fill in the rows maybe by
interpolating if you have a value above
and below then you take the mean we
should be more clever than that later
we'll look at the times and the dates
that we have and we'll draw a straight
line between two dates and then wherever
our value lies along that line that's
the value we'll give it so that's just
an interpolation between dates not
between two points that are equally
distant but for now we're going to start
easy and we're going to use a cleaning
method called drop any now if I drop in
a as it is it's going to return a data
frame and it still has rnase and that's
because a lot of what pandas does is it
operates on copies of objects and that's
for safety you often don't want to
mutate things in place but in this case
it's perfectly safe to do so so I'm
going to say do it in place
and if I run that now check out our
indices
we've lost rows two and three and we've
lost the index that belonged to them too
but now we've dropped any rows that
contain and not a number there are two
ways to do this this as I said was in
place you could also have done data is
daily drop in a because this is actually
working this part is actually dropping
me na s but then it's just giving you
back the object and you're not holding
on to it that's what we did the first
time now we're saying just set it equal
to data any questions on that one so far
all right
no because what this is doing here is
it's it's dropping those roads and that
gives us this result and then you're
saving this result on top so you you
keep the drop index you know you keep
the index where you're no longer
perfectly sequential all right so the
coffees we saw that I was a floating
point column I will confirm that again
so let me cancel this and when you say
d-types
and it's a float 64 well I want us to be
integers really so what I'm going to do
is use as type int it's like speaking
English it's so easy all right those
coffees are integers now and again I can
look at the D types from there now
64-bit integers instead of floats
how about the timestamps well if you've
ever messed with date time objects
you'll know they're generally a bit of a
pain you have to take the string and
break it up into the year in the month
in the day and the minutes you have to
drop the microseconds because who cares
and then you've got to create a
date/time object from that and that's
that's annoying
but once again pandas makes it pretty
easy we're going to say to date time all
right and now we have 8 times 64 objects
in the timestamp column
to end generally you want to cast it to
numeric first as we did numeric will
default to floats if it finds a mixed
type and we had floats first so it will
go to floats and then we do as type int
and the reason is to numeric handles the
case of error handling so if I used dot
as type int the first pass it would have
failed on that string there is no two
int method there is a two numeric and
then you turn that into an end okay
so again you've got the type sixties
okay you're probably running on a
slightly different versions and those
the defaults to 32-bit integers all
right everyone happy with that yes
it absolutely has that data and you do
have that day let me repeat the question
the index that was non-sequential after
we drop tomorrow seems strange but you
have access to this it's an actual piece
of data contained in the data frame and
what you see here is we go 0 1 4 or 5
because we drop 2 & 3 you can consider
the index a primary key if you will
there's no guarantee that your index has
to be sequential and well-formed and
unique but if you don't pass an index
into a data frame pandas will create one
for you starting at 0 and going to the
length of your data frame minus 1 and
these these objects truly are attached
to the rows and we'll find that that's
really useful later
all right everyone happy with this one
hmm so what do we stand we did some
cleaning let's use describe again if I
use describe it's only described in the
coffee's column to me now and that's
because I have a coffee's column which
is a an integer I have an object column
for the contributor and I have a
date/time column for the timestamp and
when pandas is faced with different D
types in its data frames and you asked
for describe it will default to first a
numeric values but what I can do is I
can say I can include this include
argument to see all of the information
and that just looks like this and tell
me everything so we have our count again
we saw count unique top and frequent all
right that was the first time we hit
describe and it's saying that the time
stands for 657 of them there are 657
coffees in 657 contributors that's
because we've dropped over names that's
great and then it's giving me a bunch of
nines for
you know what's the most frequent value
well what does it mean to have a most
frequent value for you know something
that's a continuous number generally it
doesn't mean much so it's telling me I
can't tell you that but it does tell me
what's the mean number of coffees with
the standard deviation what's the
minimum and maximum what are the
quartiles so that's pretty handy so we
can immediately see we started at 397
coffees and we're not 24,000 of it what
about the first few rows because we've
done a lot of changing now so how do I
get the first few rows say again
my name is luck all right so why do I
need to use Lorelai lock because this is
a data frame and if I try to access it
without the square brackets it's going
to run through my index Amanda my best
all right so here are the first five
rows this is a well-behaved integer
these things contain no more they never
contain anything bad
we have no na s here and these are
actually date/time objects which again
we can confirm using D types great so we
know how we're in a place where our data
frame is looking good
things are as they should be and the
data is ready to do some analysis on is
everyone following okay so second
did we do something with a strange it's
an object so so an object is pandas
notation for Strings strings and other
objects all right so at a glance let's
look at this time series why don't we
begin by plotting it so if I say so the
hint here is plot on the coffee series
so that's the data frame that's the
coffee series what's plotted is everyone
managing to get a graph all right
No
right hands up if you don't have a graph
do you know what the issue is
so again
[Music]
all right I'll give you just a minute
while we're waiting does anyone notice
anything strange about this graph two
time series it should be a time series
why is it clotting zero to however long
our data frame is plotting into the
index that's right also something I want
to draw your attention to is this little
spike here and what get will get rid of
that in a bit but okay so it's plumbing
into the index which is a series of
integers so it's doing something strange
it's not taking into account the
distance between date times let's use
the data frames plot method instead of a
series plot method and we can pass in
the index so my hen says plot on the
data frame which looks like that setting
X to the timestamp and then a dot dash
style so I look something like this all
right
what have I done here I've said hey plot
the whole data frame use the data use
the timestamp column as your as your X
plug anything numerical on the why I'm
here we only have one numerical thing
that's the coffee's and then style it
with dot dash which is basically a
straight line and also adults where we
have values and the reason I did that is
you can see that here there's an entire
when several months or no one ventured
any data and then here there are a few
plateaus as well I can explain these
this looks like Christmas break this
looks like
maybe Easter break or something like
that this is where I left the University
of work and this is when I came back and
visited
that's not terribly useful the
resolution here is awful so one of the
things we're going to do is get rid of
it yeah
do I need a different date table
so we don't have that problem here
because we don't have any dates with
nothing in them if you are plotting a
series that contains some na s there
would be missing chunks in the graph
okay so let's inspect the last few
points this time series just to confirm
it's what we thought it was so we had
dot head earlier but we can use tail and
I'm going to pass in N equals ten
because I want ten rows this time and so
here are the last ten rows of this data
set and what do we see
March 4th month 4th 5th 8th and then on
the 12th someone else contributed and
then someone else contributed
sporadically for about a month and then
there was nothing for five months and
then I came back and visited so that's
what we thought it was but just for
simplicity I'm gonna I'm gonna get rid
of that tail because it's not
particularly useful doesn't tell us that
much you may disagree with my choice on
that but because this is a really quick
dirty analysis we're just going to skip
it for now so I'm going to get rid of
everything after the 1st of March and
we're going to use conditional indexing
here so what does conditional indexing
look like I'm going to blank these out
first and I'm going to say data
timestamp is less than 2013 and 301
what's this going to give me a series of
series of true or false here's a boolean
excellent that's what that looks like
over the start of the time series is
before Martian 2013 well that makes
sense but we've already seen boolean
indexing we've seen how we can use a
series of trues and falses to index
across the data right and that looks
like that that's another data frame and
if I look at the tail of that it ends on
the 27th of February that's great
so we've chopped off everything after
the 1st of March just want to bring you
to the the simplicity of this we tossed
in a string as the date here and pandas
converted that to a date time for us
then filtered anything that was not less
than that
so again these are time stamps with no
time zones so I'm going to do I'm going
to cut off that tail so I'm just going
to say I'm going to take this expression
I head down here and I'm just going to
put it after the equals and say data is
the same thing as data but it's only
whatever the time stamp is less than
March 2013 and then if I look at the
tail of that that's healthy that's good
so one final look why don't we plot the
data against the timestamps do you
remember how to do that plot X is the
timestamp I'm just going to leave it as
is we don't need the start actually
let's put in the style let's do top -
again all right so we're good and by the
way you can do things like
you can pass in arguments for how big
you on the plot to be you can pass in a
title you can pass in labels all this
users matplotlib under the hood to
generate these graphs so we we see our
Christmas break again we see down I took
two months off that's not good
and then we see another kind of
Christmas break around here everyone
happy with the way we had the data set
all right let's start answering that
first question who contributed to our
data set so I'm going to look at the
contributors column that's a series
makes sense and series have a method
called value counts it's just returns a
series it's indexed by the unique values
within that series so in that case of
full of our names and then it counts the
number of times that unique value occurs
so that was a really quick quick way of
counting over all of our individual
contributors
but if you're like me you like charts
and this is kind of hard to read so why
don't we plus it so I'm going to do the
same I'm going to take beta contributor
value counts and I'm going to plus but
I'm going to pass a kind equal bar
so I'd like to thank Arturo for
contributing I'm sorry didn't need to
because when you plot a series of plots
against its index and the index of this
series is our unique names yep so I
didn't need to pass in an x value here
everyone got to this point is anyone
struggling confused behind are a few
people confused let me take two what's
up guys
okay okay I can go back over that I'm
just going to go over the chopping the
tail off really quickly alright so
here's the here's the statement I'm
going to start in the middle of those
brackets and I'm going to say the
timestamp of the data is less than March
2013
and for every row you're going to say
yes it is yes it is yes it is no it's
not and there's some point where you're
going to transition from yes to no I'm
going to use that series of yes and nose
to index my data frame and so I'm going
to say only return rows where this index
is true and so it's only returning rows
where the timestamp is less than March
2013 and then I'm setting that into my
data
all righty
I was going to keep it I wanted to see
who was contributing not because I like
seeing my name at the promise no it's
just it's just an interesting question
it's how did this dataset get built up
you want to see the same per month okay
so we're going to do some operations
later called resampling and we'll get
things into per day and per week per
month is the same we're not quite set up
for it yet what we need to do is change
our index to be a timestamp index and
we'll do that in a bit do we have a
group this is a group by contributor
here okay
all right so here's a question we looked
at who put these data points into the
data set how about on what days were
people active inputting data into the
data set
does anyone expect anything interesting
here just looking you know Mondays what
do we think well to bethe little data
writing a lot of data how about Sunday
probably not though it is a Maps
Department people were there on Sunday
so the hint here says create a series of
the weekdays for each entry so I'm going
to look at data timestamp because
there's a timestamp column it has access
to this dot DT attribute D T stands for
date/time and this opens up a whole
world of new objects to us one of which
is dolt weekday I'm going to blank those
out for now and I'm going to say hey I
just created this what does it look like
okay does anyone know what's going on
here
so is Monday look very close
it's zero to six because when asking for
the weekday not the day of the month so
yeah yeah this is still the index of my
entire data frame
we've still lost two and three and over
here zero is Monday Tuesday Wednesday
Wednesday Thursday Thursday Thursday
Thursday Thursday etc so what I'm going
to do I know it's not particularly
useful to have zero to six instead of
memorator someday we'll change that in a
minute but first I want to save this
data to my data frames it's super handy
to be able to refer and just say hey on
any given row what day was it well I'm
going to assign it to my data frame so
I'm going to use data dollar sign and I
want to say hey the weekdays column is
this weekdays object that I just created
and so then I'm going to look at the
head and I'm going to see I haven't
brand new column called weekdays which
contains the day of the week that makes
sense
why am i using dollar sign here later
we're going to use a more direct way of
adding a column pandas is incredibly
intelligent under the hood and so what
it does is it optimizes a great deal of
operations so when you use data from
your own from your own data frame and
you try to assign it in a new form to
the same data frame it may or may not
give you a warning saying hey you're
you're using a copy here instead of a
view we're using a view instead of a
copy and what that means is if your data
frame changes at a later date you may be
changing data that you didn't know you'd
be changing so often when you get that
warning it's worth heating here I got
the warning and the simple way to assign
it so I'm just going to say dot assign
which takes a copy of that instead of a
view and just slams a new column into
place everyone following alright but we
said here at the six not very helpful I
created here a standard Python list
Monday Tuesday Wednesday Thursday all
the way to Sunday I created a dictionary
that map's 0 to 6 which I got from range
7 here to this string so if I look at
what that looks like
it's a simple Python dictionary going
from zero to six and the keys Monday to
Sunday in the in the values and I'm
going to using a user function called
apply and I'm going to apply a custom
function that I'm going to write to this
column so that I can turn my zeros to
six is to Monday to Sunday so how many
people are familiar with lambda
functions all right so I'm going to use
something that's an auto lambda so I'm
going to write a function I want to say
hey they have week and it's going to
take some index and call it idx and I'm
going to say return weekday names of
that index so we take the X of that
index actually would be exactly the same
to use just the list but I want to do
this and I'm just going to show you it
works so let's print weekday dick let's
print a week of zero and I get Monday
and then if - I'm going to get Wednesday
great so that works so now I'm going to
use the supply method I'm going to say
hey data weekdays you're going to become
data weekdays where I'm going to apply a
method day of week so this is a function
I wrote is going to look at the value in
the weekdays series and whatever that
value is if it's a zero or two six it's
going to pass that as an argument today
of week and it's going to save the
result on top of it so now if I look at
data ahead my week there is a far more
human legible
any questions
okay let's group by the weekdays right
so the original question on this part of
a tutorial was on which days are people
contributing so now we have Monday to
Sunday and I want to group them up I
want to say take all of the Monday's
together and count them take all of the
Tuesday together and count them now that
sounds incredibly like values count
value councils we used earlier right so
we could use that but we're going to use
this group by which is an extremely
powerful method that just brings
anything together as you'd sell it so
you're going to say day there dot
weekdays so sorry hundred I want here
I'm going to take the data I'm going to
group it by the weekdays column and let
me show you what that looks like
currently that is a data frame group by
object it's not giving me any
information and that's because what I've
said is take all of the values in the
weekdays column and just glue them up if
they are the same so now I have seven
groups I have the Monday group the
Tuesday group amongst a group but I
haven't said what to do with those
groups well the easiest thing to do is
to count the groups and now suddenly I
have a data frame where so I have three
columns in my data frame so why am i
counting each column given that they all
have the same thing why don't I take
well I'll keep it for now
that's right I must right let's try
taking weekdays dope group a that
doesn't work let's leave it as is
alright so now what I have a data frame
where the indices are a weekday indices
that's the title they're a Friday column
contains 114 roads in all three columns
Monday is 145 Sunday is 13 I don't like
the ordering though Monday Friday Monday
Saturday Sunday Thursday or it's not
great so why don't we reorder that why
don't we say it's weekday counts and you
remember that list we had above the list
of week domains which is ordered well
I'm just going to use that
that's because
I'm sorry let me cheat
I'm doing this on the flag my dad and I
cleaning the data where do we stand on
that if you can see that this is what
that lambda would have looked like so a
lambda is just an anonymous function
it's a function that I'm saying here's a
function don't bother giving it a name
just apply it here's what that function
does okay let me go back here what did I
do wrong here well this thing is a data
frame right and if we want to access the
data frame by its index then we're going
to need to use a block it was looking
for Monday in the data frame and I was
saying where do you owe me to find
Monday I'm trying to access this by rows
quite a number of rows but you have to
say no look in the index and that's what
that does
to second please step yep so previous
step we created this function that just
returns a string and when you give it an
index for the the weekday and then we
said take the weekdays and apply that
function to it so turn those things into
that function
[Music]
how many people are still with me at
this point yes all right is everyone
happy with this step - okay
all right let's visualize these weak
accounts so we're going to do exactly
the same as we did before we're going to
take the data we had before which is
this week they count data frame and so
I'm going to take the weekday counts
which is my data frame and I'm going to
plot it and it says to plot a bar chart
so again I'm going to pass kind equals
bar all right why do we have rainbow bar
suddenly we're three columns they all
contain exactly the same thing that's
kind of useless why don't I take weekday
counts and only keep one of the columns
doesn't matter which one I keep one tube
coffees because I like coffee
all right so now we have one bar because
we're only plotting one of the columns
in that data frame and what you can see
is that Monday was definitely the day
where people into the most data
Wednesday spiked surprisingly and then
Saturday and Sunday people weren't
really there very much but that's not
negligible so it's pretty great
questions alright
also the second question it's going to
get a little bit more difficult we're
going to figure out if there are any
trends on when people drink coffee
during the week now the trend we just
saw was when do people input data that
is we were counting the rows but now we
want to count the difference in coffees
between each row I want to know on which
they are people consuming the most
coffee so here's where it gets
interesting I'm going to take this data
index which I showed you earlier was
just an integer index and I'm going to
replace it by the timestamp column on
that row
so I'm going to say data that index is
data doc timestamp so what have I done
I've replaced my index with pandas just
created for me a date time index which
contains all of my date times and see
what the data set looks like now well
instead of that zero one four five six
we now have base and remember these
aren't strings name works we cast them
to date times we also have the day time
column it contains exactly the same
information with a number of coffees the
contributor and the week day that that
day was yes we are working on the
original data frame which we've claimed
at this point I mean we still have that
object that was the weekday counts it's
still there but you know we've answered
that question just about so we're now
answering a more difficult question
which is I know you give me more data on
Monday but on which day are you going
through my coffee beads
oh the index is gone you could try the
index and say give me the row at index 4
doesn't exist if you say give me the row
at exactly this index it'll give me back
that row yeah we now have a to be a
timestamp that's it's it's not needed
yeah
so that's why this next line here says
hey why don't we drop it let's drop the
timestamp because we don't need it it's
already in the index I'm going to use
drop doc drop takes in a list of objects
to drop and usually it's going to look
for these in the indices it's going to
say oh you wanted to drop the 4th of
September but here I'm saying don't drop
a row drop a column I'm passing in the
column name and saying access equals 1
means to look at this axis look at this
axis look for the columns to drop and
then if you remember this in place
equals true back when we drop an aid we
use that to say so I don't have to say
data equals this just drop the
colonisers yes
so that's a bad place to be if there are
duplicate values in the index it'll
depend what kind of manipulation you're
doing if the type of things we're going
to be doing today it shouldn't matter if
there are duplicates but as we saw
earlier each value is unique so that's
that's great because the data frame
cannot exist without an index so I can't
drop the index so what I did is I copied
the timestamp to the index and then I'm
going to drop the column yep
[Music]
if I had a more complicated dataframe
you don't have to have the date and time
if you have a you have a date time index
where the date of the times are all big
nice we will do that later you can have
timestamp indexes with time zones
the pandas kind of date manipulation is
pretty powerful yeah
access equals one says when you're
looking for this value timestamp to go
drop usually by default it would look at
ax is zero which looks at the rows and
so it if you want to say drop zero it
would drop the row with the index 0 in
this case I want to drop any rows I want
to drop an entire column so I want to
drop something that's going down instead
of something that's going across so
that's what access equals one does so if
I run this now I no longer have that
timestamp column I have timestamp in my
index and then I have three columns
coffees contributor and weekdays
all right what I want to do now is if
accomplished
everyday at midnight and the reason is I
have a bunch of Rose sample that really
arbitrary times like a twenty two in the
morning and eleven forty eight in the
morning but I want to get one value per
day and the best way I can think of
doing that is adding in one day every
single day at midnight and then finding
the value of the number of coffees at
that point and then dropping my rows
that are not at midnight does that
operation make sense I will see it as we
go
I could but then I would be losing my
time information so here's an example
well so I wish I had a board if you have
let's say you have ten coffees today at
1:00 in the morning
and tomorrow at 1:00 in the morning you
have 20 coffees what's the value going
to be at midnight is it going to be 15
as a going to 19
well midnight is closer to 1:00 in the
morning the next day so you want the
number to be closer to that so we're
going to do a linear interpolation
between the x not we're not just going
to drop the x because they are useful to
us so here's how we do that what you saw
above was that I had a
[Music]
yep so there are some days where I don't
have anything and that will be
problematic there are some days where I
have five six seven entries and we'll
have to do something to merge those
together but more importantly if I drop
my times then if there's a man if
there's a midnight somewhere then I want
to know the two numbers to either side
of me which ones closer to me how do I
draw a straight line between those
numbers and how do I figure out what
value of coffees I should be at midnight
so this is a daytime index and you know
the first one's at a 22 and 11 48 so
we're going to create another index and
this index is going to leave outside of
a data frame first of all we're going to
create a date range and there's no date
range and it's going to start at data
got index 0 which is the first value of
the index it's going to end at data that
index minus 1 which is the last index
it's going to have a frequency of days
and then it's going to normalize equals
true what this means is make these data
points at midnight all right and so
these things don't no longer have a time
now they are just days but they are one
a day every day from the start of my
series to the end of my series let me
show you what normalize equals false
would do
everything's at 8:22 now we could do
that that's fine but it doesn't make
much sense so I want to keep it clean
have just days let me show you what
happens if we have a frequency of W what
do we get every week yep days is what we
want okay it's a daytime index of eight
times sixty four D type of frequency
days and we're 514 days everyone
following yes
because doclock returns something that's
inside a row and the index is separate
from the row so if I did any comments I
say data dot index 0 I get back that
very first time stamp if I did
locally row well 0 isn't in my index if
I did got I log 0 I get the first row
but there's no time stamp information in
that row it's hidden away in the name of
this series which is less useful so I'm
using the index directly because I can
access that so that looks like this
yes
why just because I want to keep things
clean and have one day at midnight today
I don't want I don't want to present
anyone my report and say hey here's a
list of every coffee drunk on every day
by the way the day started a twenty two
a.m. that doesn't make much sense
alright so we have this index of days
and in our data frame separately we have
an index that's kind of randomly spaced
uniform it's not a uniformly spaced data
frame or every data point every row has
the exact same interval between it
that's what our new index is for so what
we're going to do is we're going to
create a new index that takes the union
of both of those all right so our
previous index was called Midnight's so
I'm going to say hey take the indexical
Midnight's
and take the Union with our index that
is come up with a new index that has the
values of both of these indices together
in one index and make sure it's sorted
in order and that's what that looks like
so we start on October 3rd at midnight
and then we have up to the third at 8:22
and morning then we have up to the
fourth what's before that 11:48 in the
morning October 5th at midnight now you
see how this is going
cool everyone so following along great
yes
can you speak up please frequency equals
none is what it says for the granularity
there and that's because these things
are not uniformly spaced yep before the
mites it doesn't have it doesn't have a
time it's only a date if you must
together a date in a date time it's
going to give the dates midnight yeah so
that's why everything here do you folks
to midnight I don't have any duplicates
on this one
not unless somebody put in an entry
exactly at midnight we worked hard but I
don't think we worked that hard so yes
so if we turn it into midnight why are
we still seeing these roaming times
that's because this is Midnight's union
with the current index this is midnight
plus all of the stuff we currently have
now what I want to do is I want to take
my data frame which is indexed at random
times I want to slide in some indices
that are very regular and then I'm going
to have a data frame full of data and
nuns because I don't know what happens
at midnight but I know what happens you
know at 8:22 in the morning just before
that and so what we're going to be able
to do from that is fill in all the
blanks so I'll show you that in a minute
so what we can do is reinvent our data
frame so our data frame is still called
data so I'm going to take data and I'm
going to reindex hit on our new index
and let me show you what that looks like
by showing the first ten runs of that
our first time is October 3rd at
midnight we don't know how many coffees
we don't know who the contributor was we
don't know what day that is that's
because I've just invented a row and I
haven't given it any data the next is a
row that we actually had then it's
another midnight we don't know what the
information is and their names a row we
had so you're starting to see what we
can do here we can say well I want to
fill in this coffee value here and it's
somewhere between 8:00 in the morning on
the third and 11:48 on the fourth find
me a value that fits in that gap
everyone happy with that so pandas
didn't invent any data for us it just
filled everything in with I don't know
how many people are familiar yep
is NaN the default
[Music]
yes so what I could do here is I'll
figure this on the fly you could feel
Phil Knowles with one two three great
and that's useful because sometimes
nulls actually mean something
informative like my machine was broken
in this case it just means I'm creating
dates and I don't have a reading for
that date so we're going to fill those
in how many people are familiar with
interpolation okay so interpolation is
saying I have we need a board I have a
number of points and then there's this
little gap where I don't know what the
value is if I look at the points nearby
the simplest kind of interpolation is
called linear interpolation I look at
the point to the left of me at the point
to the right of me and I take an average
now I take an average make sense if I
need space between all of my points but
as we can see we're not equally spaced
so we're going to do interpolation
across time which is to say plot this
against the time axis and then wherever
the line is take that value instead
which is going to be between the value
before and the value after but it might
be closer to the value after if the time
I'm sampling out is closer to the value
after all right we're going to fill
these nine months using interpolation so
my hint says interpolate the up sample
data using the time method could it be
as simple as take the up sample data is
I'll interpolate method equals time why
yes it is this value existed this value
existed here's a midnight not a weird
number of coffees but that is the number
of coffees interpolated between these
times
we can turn it into an inch I'm not
going to bother just cuz I'm just going
to plot this but so the cool thing here
is if you take the average of these two
members it's lower than this number this
number is closer to this number because
midnight is closer to this time than it
is to this time
so we've maintained our temporal
information as we interpolate over it
yes and no you can specify column to
interpolate over but there are some some
of the more complex methods like time I
call it complex it's not really that
hard but some of the methods that aren't
just straight interpolate they will give
you a warning and say you can't do this
so let's say what happens if I take up
sample data that interpolates method
equals yes for example that gives us
here it's using the time index again so
if I say I just want to interpolate the
coffee's with the time method I think
all works here okay so I use a previous
method earlier maybe one of the
quadratic methods and it wants to use
the index for more complicated things
what we'll see later is that it's is
just nice to have in index that
represents what you're actually indexing
on
yep because we tested to date time and
if you remember if we if we look at the
index then the objects are date time
objects and it's a date time index so it
knows how to do time interpolation
alrighty it's that's where we stand now
we filled in all of those names yes
five
okay so the method equals time means
you're going to be doing a linear
interpolation where the x-axis instead
of being an arbitrary index of points is
a time value well you can use nearest I
think you can use linear as a method
I think the defaults let me see
there's a default look like the default
here is using time as well because it's
a nice and clever let's try a quick hack
let's say my data frame is is my up
sample data I'm only going to keep the
coffee's column and I'm going to say
that the index is going to be that and
what does that look like alright so now
we have how long I want to do this
before that so I'm going to use data
here all right now we have the number of
coffees
and let me set
okay that's fine
that didn't work
we think you want to fly here it smell
very nice okay how's that worked
it's still not gonna work of it oh it is
working I just keep resetting it every
time because I'm clever no I give up
we'll look at it later just in the
interest of time we're going keep going
so come on
yes okay all right we have a man all
right let's do some interpolate so just
interpolate that looks like exactly the
mean of these two values okay what
internally did by face here is it said I
don't have any information on which I
can do this I'm just going to pretend my
micro distant between point zero and
point two that is basic temporal basic
linear interpolation what we did with
the duck time method as we said use your
index it's a time index time tells you
how far points are from each other
because these rows are not actually
distant from each other use that to do
your linear interpretation I've answered
your question
differently
right yes that will work you you may
come across a problem where you have to
set that float column as your index
depending on the type of method you're
using to interpolate because over here
let's see what we have
all right here's that I don't have a
night on it and there's interpolate
let's just look at the data frame 1 so
here all of the methods you could use
and here's one we use time interpolation
works on daily and high resolution data
so that means anything with a time to
interpolate the given length of the
interval if you use linear you would
have ignored the index and treated the
values as equally spaced so had I just
read the docs I could probably have done
that from the start here was that method
we used let's use linear
stone using times and still using time
okay yeah Taylor I've already
interpolated my name's I'm not going to
bother putting them back in let's come
back to it I just want to make sure we
we finish on time okay is everyone happy
with filling in the nines as we've done
so far
yes we're now ready to resample it a
daily frequency now if you if you
remember what we had we had we had so
this would be daily if I have these rows
here and then this row but we have all
these extra things so we're we're over
daily right now and we don't want that
so I'm going to create a data frame
called daily data and it's going to use
the up sampled and I'm going to re
sample from it and I'm going to resample
daily and I'm going to use a spur freak
right let me show you without asking
first
this is a date time index resampler and
this looks curious Euler car are grouped
by object from earlier that is it's an
object that kind of has masks and things
together but it's not giving us any
information and that's because this is
very akin to a group by this is saying
look at the time stamps beam everything
in two days I just glued them in today
if these two rows fall into the same day
put them together in the same group but
I haven't told you what to do with the
group so I could do several things I
could take the mean of all the bins in
the group or I could use say the count
of everything in the group which we've
already done but what I'm going to do is
I'm going to say ask freak which is
basically saying we sample daily and
only take the tone or me take the
Midnight's on that day so it's very
helpful cuz we've put in the midnight
and we've inferred the values out those
Midnight's so we're very happy with this
now and as you can see we have lost our
time information in our index because we
don't need it anymore everything is
equally spaced one day apart alright
well we now have a contributors and a
weekdays column which we don't need and
the reason we don't need them is they're
full of nines they don't obtain any
information so here I'm only going to
drop the contributor column so I'm going
to say daily data is daily data dot drop
contributor access is once we're
dropping a column on a row so I look at
daily data now we've dropped that column
excellent and then I'm going to generate
a column for the weekday names because
remember we had these weekdays and we
figured out the weekdays where from 0 to
6 and then we applied a custom function
well I cheated you I lied
there is a weekday name attribute which
gives us that information automatically
so what have we done here we said take
the weekdays column and set it as the
index dot value name indexed or weekday
names are so you take the rate the index
which is a list of dates and then you
say what's the day of the week for each
of those and so we have that information
back so now what we have is our original
data set but instead of being sparsely
sampled at weird times it's now
uniformly homogeneously sampled at
midnight on every day yes if you have
some values for midnight when we took a
union I believe it acts like a set which
is to say that it only keeps unique
values so you would have had the number
of coffees on that date at midnight but
you would only have had one midnight
so resample basically says it's like a
group buy and it's it's a bit more
complicated than a group buy because on
a group buy we said look at the unique
values in this column you know Monday
Tuesday Wednesday and any row that has a
Monday group them into the Mondays
anyway that has a Tuesday group them
into the Tuesdays and then do something
with those groups like count the number
of things in those groups how many
things came out on a Monday that was
grouped by on it on the day of the week
resampled there's very similar but it
creates the groups for you and here it's
creating groups that are spread apart by
one day exactly so group anything that
was that landed on the fourth if you had
three things on on the fourth three
people submitted coffee values put them
into the group of the fourth and then
you could do mean which we did and I
would just say for the road that should
be the result of that on the fourth take
the mean of everything else we didn't
want the mean because if we had you know
an 8 o'clock and 9 o'clock and then
11:00 p.m. coffee we don't want to take
the mean of that and say that's what
happened at midnight we have the values
at midnight and when you want to keep
only the values at midnight and that's
what as Freak does it basically says
okay so on the third we're on the fourth
you had three values one of them have
been night one of them was at 11:00 in
the morning only keep going at midnight
it's like saying give me give me this
resemble at a daily frequency as
frequency
you don't have to speak up man what is
the unit number of coffees made up until
that date and the reason it's
floating-point now is because well some
coffee one coffee was made at 11:00
one coffee was made the next day and
this is pretending that happens at a
uniform rate yes grease sample has an on
keyword so you can resample on a column
it's going to say I don't know how to
interpret strings as dates or it might
be clever and try to cast it for you any
other questions on that all right
so let's plot this data let's see what's
more once more what it looks like and I
think I call the daily data all right
all right that looks like what we had
before
I said now we know that the data for the
coffees is no longer an integer and we
know that the times are no longer
sampled sparsely we know we know that
they're not at random times and I can
show you that by again putting a plot
sign on it
I remember these plateaus for their
Christmas break and whatever we don't
have a gap anymore we still have
something for New Year's Eve we have a
number of coffees it might not be the
exact number of coffees but we have a
value we've done a we've done a
reasonable estimate
okay how many copies were made on any
given day well what we have is a series
of how many copies were made up until
that day how many copies were made today
well it's however many we have today -
however they were yesterday and that's
just the diff that's just oh I'm getting
ahead of myself
it looks lighter let's group by week day
first of all so so coffees by day is
going to be tunes
okay it's going to be my daily data
group by is a code weekday
yep that's called weekdays and then I
want to take the mean of it all right
that's not particularly helpful
I missed a step
so yeah have you guys got this
differencing so okay let's put it in
alright let's do this okay so what I
want to do is I wanna use this oh here
we go okay
okay here's what we should have so we're
going to use death on a coffee column
and then we're going to follow up with a
shift and I'll show you why
so first I'm going to say coffees made
is my daily data dot coffees so the
number of coffees we have Bob death and
what diff does is it just looks at the
difference between any two rows and if I
look at coffees made that looks like
this so what it's done is it says let's
look at the difference between this day
in this day and put that into this cell
then let's look at the difference
between this day and this day and let's
put it into this cell now I have two
nines here the first one I already had
because I interpolated from a big night
that I didn't have data for prior to but
this one I shouldn't have and I have
this because the difference between
these first two lows I wanted to land on
here I want to say the three o'clock at
midnight I started the third on midnight
and the fourth on midnight the
differences in coffees should be
attributed to the day of the third not
the day of the fourth so we're going to
use a shift and we're just going to
shift everything by minus one shift all
of that up one great so that's coffees
made and what that says is on the fourth
3234 coffees were made on the fifth
fifty-five coffins were made that should
use a Saturday and Sunday
let's have that as a column column these
coffees made today and it's just going
to take that coffee's made series we
just created and then I'm going to look
at my data frame again and now I have a
new column with all of that information
in there and I was right
these were monday tuesday these are
Saturday so Saturday and Sunday hello
Monday 10 times as many coffees is some
day cool so far everything seems to be
in order everyone happy with what we
just did
all right now we can grid this so we're
going to group by week days and what
does that look like that's another group
by objects what we've said is anything
that's got a Monday in the weekdays
column group it into the same Gammage
and now why don't you take the mean
consider that every Monday is equal how
many copies were made on the average
Monday 34 were made on the average
Friday 37.8 were made on the average
Monday the average Sunday has a mere 15
coffees made starting to get a bit out
of a bit of insight out of this but
we're going to sort that out because we
didn't like that so coffees by day is
going to be week
all right so remember we had that list
Monday does some day yeah two sides
here I didn't do I did not use a sign so
what happened was this calculation on
the top row this is this returns a copy
simple operations will return a view and
what that says is it's like pointers if
you're familiar with that in C or C++
you have your data actually points to
somewhere else and then it calculates
things on the fly for simple operations
for complicated ones here I'm doing a
DIF and then it shift and the shift is
going to break things
the shift is going to say I'm just going
to wrap this round one I'm going to
create a new object for that and
therefore I was able to safely assign
this column here this is most often I
would say in my experience anyway I've
been able to use this most of the time
occasionally I get this weird warning
and I have to dot assign it to do that
safely in the notes on these slides
there are a couple of Stack Overflow
posts and you'll see the the people
explaining why you want to do this when
you should heed the warning
sometimes the warning is ignored because
it raises false positives yeah alright
we've grouped them up we know how many
copy coffees are made on the average day
but again it's going Friday Monday
Saturday so we're going to sort that out
and then we're going to plot coffees by
dad or plots and we're going to plot
another bar
what did I do
and countries by day week day names is a
list that's fine
coffees by day is a data frame so I
can't access it that way so I'm going to
access using the index that's much
better
and then I can plot the bar chart and
did I break everything well I want to
plot only the coffee's made today I
don't want to plot the total coffees
there we go alright so we're back to
what we had before a Monday on the
average Monday thirty seven coffees are
made Tuesday a little bit more Wednesday
big spike hard day Wednesdays were
seminar days someone will come and give
a talk at lunchtime and everyone would
sit around the coffee first and discuss
things so that makes sense
I'm glad Thursday was clearly the hard
day and then Friday people slacked
already last couple of questions how
many coffees did people drink and this
is we're going to see a little bit more
of the power of pandas here all thing
you don't have a nice clean data set in
tabular form you often have five six
seven different places to source your
data from the indices won't match and
you still have to join these together so
we're going to do a join here first
we're going to load in this data set
called people which just contains a
daily index and the number of people in
the department at the time so if you
remember how to do that we're going to
read this is everything panelist can
read from by the way whoever's going to
read from CSV again and it's in data
Department members and that looks like
this it's once a month at the end of
August there were 12 people at the end
of September there were 14 people ok
really nice simple data set how do we
join something that's monthly to our
data set that's daily
well first we're going to do an outer
join does anybody want to know what a
what a join is okay those are bad
question so what a join is going to do
is is going to look at two data sets
it's going to compare one of the columns
that you're telling it to look at
generally that'll be the index but you
can tell it to look elsewhere and you're
going to say wherever these indices
match create you know extend that row
the defaulting parameters is an inner
join which is to say if my first data
set has an index which doesn't appear in
my second data set
drop that row an outer join does the
opposite it says if this one has an
index in this one doesn't keep that row
and just fill it with man so we're going
to do daily data is daily data drawing
I'm going to on people and I'm going to
do an outer join on that what does that
look like let me just
see what that looks like all right so
what we have is on the third we have
this nun we had before on the fourth we
have everything that looks fine and then
we have a bunch of man's for dates and
members so the dates here is going to be
man's all the way down until we hit the
the end of the month because that's when
we had our data but so one thing we can
do is interpolate over using the nernst
and I'm using nearest here because
no I'm using merest because the points
now equally spaced so if I look at that
that breaks those mr. Prem paren is bare
it's just not showing over here so I'm
using this new notebook edition so this
is a Jupiter notebook but I'm using it
in flight mode and I'm running it live
at the same time and occasionally things
are difficult I mean take this how does
it differ it doesn't differ
oh yes you're right when we loaded this
in I forgot to read half of my
instruction parse the dates all right
well let's say the index column is the
column called dates and power spades
equals true so let me space that out a
little bit that's a cheat we're cheating
all the way through all right how does
that look all right this has changed the
date is now our index because we said
the index column should be the date and
let's just confirm that it's what we
want it to be about the index it's a
date time index excellent it's managed
to parse those dates so our data frame
looks like that and now we can do a join
so this should be correct so we're going
to take the daily data which we had
before let's the coffee data we're going
to join it to the number of people in
the department in announcer join let me
show you what that looks like
and I can't do it twice so that looks
like that so on the end of August we had
12 people but we have no idea how many
coffees we're on the end of September no
idea how many coffees but we had 14
people and then first of October we
started recording coffees 3rd of October
without arguments it's running on the
index so because it's an outer join it's
saw this and said that this doesn't
exist in my daily data so create a row
that has a bunch of bands in it and then
from the people data that's where I got
the index from put that in there good
question so there is an excellent
article on here that's called merge-join
and concatenate and it will run through
every possible example of how ever you
possibly want to join your data in every
different form it is incredibly
elaborate you can ignore the index you
can just show columns on and don't worry
if they're aligned you can do all sorts
by grid teas anyway the one thing I want
to do now though is I want to
interpolate over this members thing
because we have a bunch of Mane's which
we don't particularly like we want to
fill those it so we're going to say
daily data is daily data that
interpolate and I think I want
interpolate sorry daily data
I was just trying to appellate method is
nearest all right here's the head of our
data frame let me have a few more rows
we had a bunch of man's here but now
they've been filled out may even fill
out the 14 because on this date there
were 14 people here we didn't know that
the nearest is 14 here we didn't know
that the nearest is 14 so we've
interpolated by just pushing that
forward it didn't interpolate on these
three nines because there's nothing
above it and it didn't interpolate on
these because these are this is a string
okay everyone happy with that that's
just an interrelated as we did before
let's create a column from the number of
coffees per person this is an important
question
so coffees per person is going to be
daily data adults coffee news made today
and what am I going to do with that
divided by daily data can I do this
daily data divided by so coffees made
today divided by numbers which was the
number of people in my department and
now we have a coffees per person column
and on this Tuesday it was 2.4 on the
Wednesday seminar day for looking good
and again we can I can show you a few
more rows Thursday was exceptionally
nasty and then Saturday and Sunday we
didn't have that many coffees all right
starting to get close now let's plot it
so 30 data about coffees four-person
plots and ok and what is going on all
right I'm going to ask for a couple of a
little bit of input what is going on
with all this up and down on sirs
so again it's not a discrete data
problem this is a weekend effect now
what you're seeing is the drop at the
weekend and the raise during the week is
hard to see but that's what it is what
about here
so is it vacations is it market days is
it that the machine is broken
sadly this occurred to us a few times
and we were all very desperate by the
end of it but I have that data for you
so let's use read CSV to figure out
there about coffee status and I'm going
to read the full instructions this time
so parse dates so I'm going to pass an
index call it is again the date and I'm
going to parse dates it's true what does
that look like horse dates cool all
right
status is OK on those first five days
well that's great but that doesn't tell
us much what are the values in this
column well we can use machine status
dot status that is the series remember
and we can do a value counts on that so
there are only two statuses okay and
broken it could also be a little crying
face but 88 days the machine was broken
let's plot that I want to see when
things break I'm going to do a little
trick I'm going to say numerical status
is the machine status dog status equals
okay what is this statement doing
Sears amongst trues and falses this is
going to say for every row when the
status is okay on that row return true
and otherwise return false
and fortunately trues and falses years
and ones can be plotted as zeros and
ones and so here we have over time
because our index is at time date time
index we have one it was okay it was
okay it was okay it broke for a little
bit it was okay it broke it came back
for a few days it broke again I remember
that time it was very sad all right we
have this plot let's join it to our
growing data set so let's say daily data
is daily data drawing on machine status
it should be as easy as that great
here's our status
and let's bring in that numerical
representation of trues and falses
rather than okay and broken so I'm going
to say daily data dots status is equal
to okay same thing we did to create a
series but now I'm just putting it
straight into a column crew room through
through we have a false here because we
didn't have an entry on this date that's
okay what we can do now though is we can
plot both of those things on the same
chart so this is called daily data I'm
going to take daily data and we're going
to plot it as is and actually I'm going
to plot both columns because here I have
overpowering everything is the number of
copies made to date how do I select two
columns I pass a list to the index so
I'm going to pass status and coffees
made today all right
plotting status didn't help because it
was okay and broken but what if I pass
the numerical status let me go and do
daily data numerical status I'm going to
times you by a hundred all right that
looks better
all right so whenever this blue line
crashes down the machine is broken and
we can see that coincides spectacularly
with these moments where people didn't
drink coffee so we're happy with that
valley to zeros
and that is due to us interpolating on
daily basis so the diff is is not zero
because by the time I started measuring
again the machine have been back in some
coffees have been drunk and we spread
that death out across those days all
right strong weekend effect didn't like
it when we resample that so when we say
daily data so weekly data is going to be
the daily data a dot I'm going to
resample gayleen resemble weekly now and
remember resampling weekly is going to
say create a bin for every week every
data point that falls within a week
group it into that bin and then I'm
going to take the mean of all of those
points that fall into those weekly bins
and then I can say weekly data dot plot
and I'm going to plot again coffees made
today and miracles status so that's that
data frame and I'm going to plot it all
right so blue is our coffees made and
it's much smoother than it was now I'm
gonna ask you to squint a little bit and
say that Oh across time here was fairly
constant maybe a little bit of like the
post Christmas rush to get some papers
out and then what's this bit here this
dip happens during the summer months
that's conference E isn't that it's too
nice to be working on outside and then
these clashes they've smoothed out a
little bit because we've averaged those
two we've made those weekly things but
they still coincide very very well with
where those coffees are not at the usual
level so just to wrap up here what have
we achieved today well we started by
cleaning the data sets so we cast
columns that were incorrect types to
their correct types we dropped some rows
with no data and then we truncated a
time series when things got a bit weird
and people stopped submitting data
we explored the contributions so we
discovered who contributed to the data
set how many people by how much and we
established when on which days of the
weeks where those contributions made we
export the time series by resampling to
a daily basis we interpolated over those
missing values to figure out what this
value should be we discovered on what
days of the week coffee was primarily
popular and that was on Wednesday for
seminars we joined the data set to
others and that's always half the battle
anyway then we derive some new columns
from the existing ones we smoothed it
out by down sampling and so the insights
we got out of this was they weren't that
many people contributing to this data
set it was nine but given that on most
days we had maybe 12 13 14 people in the
department that's pretty good
participation contributions were lacking
at the weekends months because nobody
was at the office
Monday's had the most contributions and
seminar Wednesday is a strong driver of
coffee consumption makes sense
periods of low coffee drinking they
matched up with peers when the machine
was broken and there was a dip in the
summer months as people were away so I'm
gonna wrap it up there and take any
questions you might have
thank you